[Music]
foreign
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
I'm Peter Morgan uncensored tonight
another bombshell pole shows half of the
king's Realms want to ditch the monarchy
with many exciting Colonial sins as the
reason for divorce so should King
Charles apologize for the past maybe
even pay reparations or would that just
fan the Republican flames
Hollywood's nauseating hypocrisy laid
bearers Met Gala Stars pay tribute to
the late Carl Lagerfeld and venomous
provocative who disagree with them about
pretty much everything should these
wokies practice what they preach or
maybe just stop preaching we'll debate
that
The Legend official in America Sparks
fire and Thunder by coming out as a
woman of color of course he did it as a
prank to test this concept of Limitless
self-identity so what's the problem well
the black lesbian representative of
Delaware who is a white bloke will join
me live to explain
[Music]
from the news building in London this is
Piers Morgan uncensored g'day people
Amanda welcome to Piers Morgan on sense
that Hollywood loves nothing more than
telling the rest of us how we should
live and how we should think it's heavy
on the preach light on the practice this
week stars and supermodels flew in on
private jets taking a very well-earned
break from haters about their carbon
footprint attention for detail for the
Met Gala in New York and what is now
routinely a nauseating annual romp of
tone death extravagance became a
glistening exhibition of Holly woke
hypocrisy well the whole event was built
as a tribute to the late Fashion King
Carl Lagerfeld indisputably one of the
all-time great designers a visitor from
outer space will be forgiven for
thinking he was some kind of hybrid
non-binary Fusion of Mother Teresa and
Nelson Mandela by the time this night
would finish the other night but let's
compare and contrast some of lagerfell's
opinions with those peddled by the Stars
oozing their tributes to him on the red
carpet here's Margot Robbie
this is actually yeah yeah this um dress
was worn by Cindy Crawford in 1993. they
remade it for me and it's uh obviously a
call design and I feel really great in
it actually it's incredible obviously
the Met's always an exciting night but I
had the great privilege of Getting to
Know Carl to an extent I was the last
Chanel Ambassador that he picked what an
honor yeah it is an honor
nobody bows in admiration more to
Margaret robber than me one of the great
actresses in the world right now and a
lovely lady met her a couple of times
but that's the same Margot Robbie who's
a vocal advocate for gay marriage
famously wearing a pro-gay marriage
t-shirt for an appearance on Saturday
Night Live I've got no issue with that
obviously
but Lagerfeld did I'm against gay
marriage he told Vice magazine the same
year before launching a stunning
broadside against gay parents adopting
children
surely some mistake Margot
and then it was Jared Leto dressed up as
a cat in homage apparently to Carl
lagerfeld's beloved pet
and yeah here has been celesto in 2015
giving an impassioned speech about
refugees of the Syrian crisis
by the way many of us here
are the sons and the daughters of
immigrants
[Applause]
and Steve Jobs
the Sun
of a Syrian immigrant
very moving very laudable but what about
his hero carlographer well in a shocking
interview on the same Refugee crisis he
evoked the Holocaust to attack former
German Chancellor Angela Merkel for
taking in too many refugees from Syria
or the enemy of the Jewish people is he
effectively called them the list of the
double standard goes on Kim Kardashian
joined the sycophantic parade of course
she did she'd turn up the opening of a
paper envelope but despite Lagerfeld
saying she was to blame for a robbery
that she suffered in Paris because she
flaunts her wealth on Instagram he
literally victim blamed her but she
forgave him because she gets the chance
to wear a nice dress in a tributed Carl
Lagerfeld it'll be the center of media
attention which is really what she loves
doing most never mind the hypocrisy and
then there's that my old friend Emily
balachowski a vocal body positivity
Advocate lioness of the metoo movement
appeared to have forgotten that
lagerfell must describe curvy women as
fat mummies and said models should
expect to be great
this is the same ridiculous hypocrisy
that leads to fugitive pedophile Roman
Polanski bagging an Oscar and a standing
ovation after his conviction an ovation
led by Meryl Streep while the rest of us
are just invited to forget about it
now I've had many run-ins with the
British actress and activist Jamila
Jamil she can be incredibly irritating
and she would say exactly the same thing
about me but today she wrote this in
response to the Met Gala this isn't
about cancer culture it's not even about
Carl it's about showing how selective
Council culture is within liberal
politics in the most blatant way so far
it's about showing why people don't
trust liberals because a slippery double
standards like this
well for possibly the first time ever
maybe the only time ever I agree with
her she's right if you're going to use
your positions of privilege to preach
woke morality for the minions back home
you should start by practicing
yourselves and maybe avoid treating as
your hero somebody whose opinions are
the complete opposite to Everything You
Preach well we'll debate that later in
the program but first a new bombshell
poll published today shows that nearly
half of the king's Realms would vote to
become republics if they had the chance
Caribbean countries cite Colonial ties
as the reason for wanting to part with
the monarchy and pretty disturbingly for
King Charles 10 of the 14 countries
polled so they backed the sussexes
saying Megan's treatment exposes racist
views it's ignited debate about whether
King Charles should apologize for
Britain's past sins maybe even pay
reparations would that make any
difference would it just fuel the fire
of republicanism well here would be now
to debate this is the former Royal
Butler to Princess Diana Paul Burrell
the activist and organizer of black
lives matter protest Iman ayton and the
historian and Royal author Dr Tessa
Dunlop well this will be a quiet debate
won't you
well you brought your earplugs Paul um I
won't get a look in well let me let me
start with you I've got a problem with
this constant looking back in history
feeling ability for stuff that none of
us in this era actually did and then
having to say sorry for everything that
we didn't do and even now apparently
having to pay people today the stuff
that happened to their ancestors many
generations before I don't really get
what that achieves we should learn from
lessons of the past
um we can't change anything
um and we should move forward but the
Queen's greatest achievement his
mother's greatest achievement was the
Commonwealth of countries she was very
proud of that I think if she could beam
her down now she would say my
Commonwealth that should survive intact
into the king's Reign so he should do
whatever he can now bear in mind I've
known this man for a very long time he
has a voice and what and he he will say
what he here's the real problem he's got
there's another voice yapping away yes
about racism two voices his son Harry
yes and Harry's wife Megan who for three
years have branded the royal family a
bunch of callous racist that is now
turning up in in these holes because
understandably frankly yes black people
in the Commonwealth around the world are
going whoa really they're racist these
people and yet they haven't produced a
shred of evidence for any of it you and
I know the royal family are not racist
and you and I know that they press the
races button on the Oprah Winfrey Show
yeah and they never apologize to the
queen never she went to her grave
thinking there was a racist in the royal
family they said what happened we never
didn't say that the president mean to
say it was racism well you correct it
Harry why didn't you tell you well we
know why because it made them it made
them they weaponized racism and mental
health to make themselves extremely rich
I totally all right come on this is my
problem this has always been my problem
with this racism narrative that these
two have spun without any evidence is
that people around the world
particularly people of color they
believe it and why wouldn't they believe
it they're hearing the first person who
wasn't a white Royal bride say they're
racist these people so the damage is is
palpable it's tangible and it will lead
I think if we're not careful to a load
of these countries becoming republics
and the beginning of the end of the
monarchy
thank you thank you
all right no problem so first and
foremost my feelings on the royal family
and racism are not predicated on Harry
and Megan's willingness to identify
that's the difference between me and you
we are talking about a country that was
built off of racism and we are referring
to the oldest institution in this
country that started at all so that's
the first thing in terms of why black
people and many others feel the way that
we do well the monarchy is a symbol of
white supremacy okay white supremacy
that is the reason let me why does it
make any difference if King Charles says
sorry or why does it if he pays money
what difference does that make
okay so record combat racism no it
actually does so let me guys we've got a
racist bone on his body he's done more
for racism than any public figure in the
country why should he be paying for the
sins of people hundreds of years ago
okay so can I finish yes thank you very
much so
the monarchy is a symbol of white
supremacy which is what black people
have had to contend with for the last
400 years notwithstanding the fact that
Elizabeth or every king and queen from
Elizabeth I think the last queen was
that was a model of white supremacist
finish let me finish my point you just
ask me several questions let me finish
I'll answer the question why I'm getting
there so just finished okay so if
every king queen from Elizabeth the
first one in the fourth has supported
and profited off of slavery so it this
is about the fact that this country was
built off of racism and that is that
this country also happened this country
because I haven't even finished my
appointment you can't just meet his
statements about our royal family don't
expect me to jump in keep interrupting
can I finish this country also led the
world out of slavery okay so can I
finish my point a long time ago can I
finish my point please yes perfect
please finish it I will no problem just
be patient so every single king and
queen from Elizabeth first willing the
fourth over 270. supported the
enslavement of Africans and profited as
a result so different it is and this
country yes hold on a second it doesn't
take a genius to figure out that this
country was built off of racism and it
stems from white supremacy all of which
is directly attributed to the crown to
favor influence them to us let me finish
keep talking cares you keep interrupting
answer my questions let's have a
conversation answer my questions
hey guys I spoke about slavery let me
answer my question I asked
for what happened centuries ago or
paying money for it okay so what you're
talking about is slavery I'm not talking
about slavery so if you can be traced
back to Europe the Greek slave trade to
be specifically 400 BC than the Roman
Empire and then we get to the Muslim
conquest of seven Century people had
slaves what we're talking about right so
we're not talking about slavery comes in
many years
talking about colonialism neon colorism
racism disparities and the racist system
of Oppression exploitation of black
people and white supremacists which
should bring me Bandits under the ground
so you've got to do with King Charles I
am telling you why he needs to apologize
and pay record
what did he do I'm telling you
colonialism neocolonialism the spices in
a racist system or white supremacist
attributes that is the legacies of the
crown slavery
I understand let me finally get my point
across Lord checkpoint across but here's
my point my Counterpoint to you what's
any of that got to do with King Charles
okay who actually has been I think one
of the great standard bearers in Royal
history for actually promoting racial
inequality and tackling racial Injustice
you want him to be issuing groveling
apologies for people hundreds of years
ago and you want him to pay money okay
so I think black people will be far more
inclined to get over it if it wasn't for
the fact that the legacies of the crown
slavery and colonism still remain which
includes racism racial disparities and
the racist global system of Oppression
and exploitation of black people oh
you're not answering my questions but
you don't want to accept it
you haven't explained
as as a result of expectation of black
people and you also have that speak now
hold on you haven't even let me finish
this no problem no problem you've done
nine tenths of the talk no no you didn't
let me know sir
you've heard the debate I think you're
both wrong actually on the one hand we
celebrate and you certainly do peers the
idea of monarchy is continuity yeah
going way back when I mean I read an
article this week that traced the
anointing oils to the Old Testament and
King Solomon you can't pick and choose
which bits of that continuous historic
line you like yes I can well how was
that um you can but it's hugely
problematic and I would counter to you
where we have the face of history and
the and the physical form of history in
our royal family
when for example France the Republic
outlawed slavery much later and in The
Civil Wars in America that's what it
took in America
but you interact with me you did all the
Talking I see your hypocrisy right now
what we're doing here is relating an
individual family with institutions of
State you can't expect a king to
apologize he doesn't have that power he
would have to be told to Apologize by
the government because it's an
institution of states do I have to all
right excuse me
you keep talking about slavery let's
speak clear about slavery yes you did
end slavery you've made that point and
you've made that point so let me address
it you did end slavery and there was a
clause in the contract that said for
example that Jamaicans had to work up to
45 hours a week for the following four
years while she simultaneously paid off
the slave owners and left the enslaved
in their countries to watch and then he
transition to colonialism where slavery
still continued and then you transition
to the commonweal
[Music]
time out
the biggest problem with slavery right
now is there are between seven to ten
million slaves in India last time I
looked that is not as a result of white
supremacy causing modern day slavery I
would rather we expend all our energy on
current slavery issues than going back
in the past as we now do we now go back
in the past for everything wallowing in
self-guilt about stuff that nothing to
do with us legacies
legacies of the crown saving colonialism
you ignored that's convenience this is
negative this isn't negative going back
how far do you want to go back 400 years
okay I told you that so do you think the
Vikings should be paying me money for
what they did to me so you're talking
about slavery I am not I would explain
what's on my slavery I'm talking about
colonialism
that's still contested stop shouting
you're not listening to what I said
you're not listening to me should the
Vikings and the Romans also through
their modern day ancestors be be paying
me reparations for what they did to my
family so I'm not talking about slavery
I'm talking about colonialism it's not
slavery you're not listening to me yes I
am the Vikings and Romans didn't make it
slaves no yes you're talking about the
Roman Empire which included no I'm
talking about the Romans and the Vikings
coming over here and causing a
measurable harm to my ancestors
in one sentence one sentence Iman Iman
in one sentence go ahead what do you
want in one sentence
but I want money from the Vikings and
the Romans
no but the Commonwealth do is a Force
for good yes yes it is they do
absolutely work for each other it's a
family a community of families that help
each other that's why it was formed and
no you benefit more that's why it's
formed no we don't benefit they benefit
as well they do benefit of course you do
oh yes they do yes I'm not saying that
they don't what I'm saying is that we
benefit
how much money do you want from me
that's what I keep talking about how
much money do you want from the national
Commission on reparation said that
Jamaica for example is is how much do
you want from me trillion how much do
you want from me top up my feelings and
not from you I'm not this isn't about me
we've all got a chip in right so yeah
how much money could I give you for
something that had nothing to do with me
right that's what I wanted how much
money could I give you to make Legacy to
make racism better nothing we're talking
about the legacies of the clown slaving
clones
I don't know why you've come on deciding
to speak like a robot today it's not
it's not really working listen because
you don't listen that's why that nor
just talking to me like that doesn't
work okay well how about this I will
happily listening if you could convince
me that it will change racism one iota
of this country I will pay you a check
for the damage inevitably that was done
by my relatives when they weren't being
attacked by Vikings and Romans I I will
pay you reparations if I think you have
any argument for why I should and you
know what there isn't one can I give
yours that's it that's the point guys
thank you all very much indeed I'm
sensitive next is the King's coronation
the final hurray for brand Britannia or
Tina Brown the queen of Royal commentary
weighs in from across the pond that's
next
[Music]
thank you
for the real crown experience tune in to
talk TV all this week for a right Royal
point of view don't miss Piers Morgan
very smartly he's now moving to save the
monarchy Jeremy Kyle it really is a
Monumental moment whether you're a
monarchist or not Vanessa Felts we can't
wait we're counting down we've got the
mug we've got the Bunting and TV Queen
Mrs o he is a humanitarian and he's
going to do a great job only on top TV
foreign
[Music]
thank you
he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
thank you
foreign
for the real crown experience tune in to
talk TV all this week for a Ride Royal
point of view don't miss Piers Morgan
very smartly he's now moving to save the
monarchy Jeremy Kyle it really is a
Monumental moment whether you're a
monarchist or not Vanessa Felts we can't
wait we're counting down we've got the
mug we've got the Bunting and TV Queen
Mrs o he is a humanitarian and he's
going to do a great job only on top TV
[Music]
thank you
and breathe well welcome back to
Pittsburgh on sense of assessing
Britain's monarchy as a brand might seem
superficial even sacrilegious but not to
the Royals who have seen themselves as a
family business ever since George VI
nicknamed them the fern the British
Monarchy has long been a global
Juggernaut as a brand of a late Queen
was its brand ambassador and an amazing
one of that but will the monarchy under
King Charles continue to stoke Global
Intrigue well some commentators of half
that the coronation will be the
monarchy's last Imperial hurray and they
decline in the number of U.S media Crews
at Saturday's event indicates maybe the
Royal Sparkle is dimming well joining me
now is Tina Brown author of The Palace
papers alongside Paul and Tessa Tina
great to talk to you I can't think of
anyone better to put all this into be
happy I'm very happy to hear you you
know trashing the Vikings you know well
you know what I just think once you get
it it's time they got cancer
but once you go back in history looking
for people who've invaded places and
demanding you want money for it we're
all going to get quids in and the entire
world goes bust anyway that's not why
I've got you on um see them put me put
me into proper perspective about where
we are with the monarchy with King
Charles and the future because it seems
to me we've reached a real a difficult
moment I think for that for the
monarchies Institution for the country
and Anything Could Happen
well it is a very sort of pivotal moment
that Charles has taken over I actually
think it's probably a good thing it was
him not William because in a sense he's
going to be this kind of sorbet course
between the two Reigns right and he's
got to somehow get out of the last
Reigns uh sort of extraordinary Charisma
that it had and positioning the next
Reign for William and actually I think
he's going to be much better than just a
transitional Monarch because he is a
really accomplished Statesman I think
one of the things I think people hear
are quite surprised at those who pay
attention which isn't very many I'll be
honest but those who do are quite
surprised at just how well Charles has
handled this whole interregnum if you
like uh between the Queen's death and
and him taking over starting right when
he came out of the box right after the
queen died wonderful human excellent you
know speech uh terribly dignified you
know doing the during the funeral and
actually has weathered the whole kind of
Sussex grudgernaut
um with tremendous kind of Applause but
here's the butt I would put in the
spanner in the works if you like there's
no doubt that he's worked I think in
this country the latest poll shows still
a significant majority in favor of a
monarchy many echoing the points you've
just made about how Charles has handled
it so far and I totally concur with that
but there's a pretty worrying poll about
the rest of the Commonwealth where a lot
of countries have fed into this Sussex
narrative that the Royals are racist and
they're moving fast towards a republic I
interviewed the Prime Minister of
Australia uh yesterday he's a die-hard
republican no doubt there's going to be
a referendum I think in probably in his
second term if he wins it and that could
well go the wrong way for the monarchy
and that could be like a domino effect
if we're not careful
I'm not so sure though that The
Sovereign Realms are in anybody's
expectations that that's going to
continue I mean if there are any solving
Realms by the time uh William takes over
I'd be very very surprised and actually
I think that Charles is fairly sanguine
about that you know inevitability of
that happening the fact is that this is
a time of huge transition I mean the
queen you know that the Commonwealth was
the Queen's great love and it made her a
kind of a global Monarch but those times
have changed I mean you saw how terribly
they've changed I mean how amazingly
they've changed just by that whole you
know messed up Royal tour of William and
Kate when they went to Jamaica they were
doing all the same old things but
suddenly they were in the wrong movie
you know it just suddenly looked like
wait a minute the world has changed
you're doing the same things so I don't
think those I don't think that the
Commonwealth uh as Sovereign Realms will
continue but I do think that the
Commonwealth as a club of Nations you
know Allied by trade you know values
shared values uh shared sense of you
know Fair elections all of those things
that is going to be still I think a very
powerful club and I think Charles is
probably quite uh reconciled to that
actually what should he do about the
Duke and Duchess of Sussex should they
remain able to use their titles to
generate such huge income
I'll tell you I think you've lost drugs
out we'll sort that then we'll come back
and sort Tina's uh Micah there's a quick
loan with me now isn't it
I should yeah what should they do I
should I tell you what react to first of
all what Tina said about this
Commonwealth do you agree with that I I
do think it's it is inevitable we will
lose Australia and and Canada I do and
you make huge I think that's all I don't
know about Jamaica but I do think the
the common I think quite a few Caribbean
countries the Commonwealth should stay
together it's a it works does it matter
yes what really infuriates me is how bad
the reporting is nobody fully seems to
understand the difference between the 14
Realms which I don't think Charles will
end up remaining ahead of state of and
the Commonwealth by the way in which
countries who cast off our King remain
in the Commonwealth is this grouping and
you know what's so crucial about it it's
away from the hoof of America something
we do and many of the countries are
smaller and parallel by climate change
together we're greater no that's a good
point okay we've got Tina back Tina we
left the viewers on a cliffhanger of
whether a child should strip his son
Harry and a Megan of their titles should
they be allowed to continue to exploit
the Royal titles whilst causing clearly
demonstrable damage to the institution
that afforded those titles on them
well I mean I think that you know
there's probably uh quite a lot of
personal emotional desire to do that but
anybody uh smart advising Charles would
say don't do it because the fact is that
if he strips them of their titles they
have a whole new Grudge Match uh to go
to town with and right now they're sort
of fading is the truth both I think in
the U.S and in the UK certainly as kind
of Fascination figures I mean they're
now in their next kind of phase where
they're simply going to have to prove
themselves uh in terms of celebrity
content I mean it's all going to be
about what's next you know I know that
Megan is scrambling very hard now to
kind of figure out what is she going to
do now with this huge deal she had from
Netflix to you know create content she
actually hasn't done any content except
for the the documentary so people are
looking at them and thinking well okay
we had that that was great you were you
were a massive celebrity for you know
the rest of for the whole of the end of
last year what's next what's next then
now having to manufacture product yeah I
mean there's a limit there's a limit to
how much wine it's a complete limit well
it limits how much whining you can do
and how much the public will stomach I
mean their popularity that's absolutely
plummeted on both sides of Atlantic
their USP is being Royal right and
whilst ever they're Royal and have
titles they can make money because they
are considered to be the royal family in
America
Charles cannot he can't take the titles
away from them because Harry was born a
royal Prince so that makes Megan a
princess didn't change the letters and
Tina said this at the beginning of the
interview was not many people really
care about King Charles and I think we
talk all the time about Harry and Megan
because we don't want to face the truth
which is the dude at the top at the
moment the guy is going to get coronated
on Saturday just isn't frankly that
interesting okay Tina the other person
who's getting a crown on Saturday of
course is Camilla what an amazing
journey it's been for Camilla I mean if
you go back after Diana died she was the
most reviled woman in Britain and now
she's going to be cried she was so
reviled you remember they called a old
boot old bag vampire I mean the list of
epithets that we used about it there was
even you know a restaurant dish called
smoked had Parker bowls at one point it
was in such a terrible repute but you
know she just she's exactly proved about
just playing the long game you know she
has got uh Elizabeth II like uh sort of
durability
um and and you know sort of patience
quite honestly which has really been
remarkable interestingly she hasn't
really broken through in the United
States at all one of the problems for
Camilla here is that first of all she's
still really if anybody does think about
her through the they think about it
through the prism of Diana you know who
always saw her as the usurper the
Rottweiler that is kind of faded the
trouble is that Ashley can't do a TV
interview because that would be very
unwise and Camilla is not as unwise as
everybody else in her family have done
the TV interview she's not going to fall
into that trap and do it so how does she
in a sense you know project the sort of
warm human numerous person that she
actually is in the United States they
don't get it at all they think that she
is a sort of they get her completely
wrong here I mean they think that she's
a kind of a quote battle Ark so you know
a a sort of a a wannabe I mean they use
the most extraordinary adjectives about
it when they talk about it to me I said
no you get a completely wrong yeah you
know she's not like that at all but
quite hard for I think now to break
through and I don't think she's probably
ever going to here finally Tina will you
be watching tomorrow
I'm going to be commentating with CBS so
I shall be speaking to the Great America
well I'll be anchoring for Fox
we'll both have our Vantage points but
it's going to be an amazing event and I
think I mean the one thing it will do it
does remind people that we might not be
great in many other ways now but boy can
we put on some Pomp and pageantry
apparently the procession on Saturday
will be twice as big as the one for the
Queen's funeral and three times as big
as the one for the Platinum Jubilee
it's going to be absolutely glorious and
the truth is that of course for all the
kind of so-called lack of Interest here
once that starts people will be sitting
there in their pajamas at five o'clock
in the morning completely glued to it
and just marveling will you be saying
it's going to be fabulous of Allegiance
I'm not so crazy about that Earth
oh my god when did we become North Korea
I mean I just don't think he's gonna fly
I hope it's not going to just be this
sort of giant National raspberry that's
kind of you here it's relaxing
breath of the country because whoever
had got overexcited and suggested that I
think it was being part with the
Archbishop of Canterbury uh Tina great
great to talk to you and best of luck
going forward there's going to be the
head of the head of an occasion and I
appreciate you taking time to join us
thank you very much thank you and thanks
to my excellent pack as always ran says
next a U.S politician takes the brave
decision to come out as a lesbian woman
of color sparkling calls them to resign
but why why was he not entitled to
re-identify himself uh well he she they
will join me live after the break
[Music]
for the real crown experience tune in to
talk TV all this week for a Ride Royal
point of view don't miss Piers Morgan
very smartly he's now moving to save the
monarchy Jeremy Kyle it really is a
Monumental moment whether you're a
monarchist or not Vanessa Felts we can't
wait we're counting down we've got the
mud we've got the Bunting and TV Queen
Mrs o he is a humanitarian and he's
going to do a great job only on top TV
thank you
[Music]
he's back and he's uncensored debating
the breaking news and talking to the
biggest names Piers Morgan is live every
week with a host of stars uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember
you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
thank you
for the real crown experience tune in to
talk TV all this week for a right oil
point of view don't miss Piers Morgan
very smartly he's now moving to save the
monarchy Jeremy Kyle it really is a
Monumental moment whether you're a
monarchist or not Vanessa Felts we can't
wait we're counting down we've got the
mud we've got the Bunting and TV Queen
Mrs o he is a humanitarian and he's
going to do a great job only on top TV
[Music]
this is talk TV
welcome back to Piers Morgan Center the
county politician in Indiana United
States is making headlines this week by
well exploring his identity
a councilman is coming out as a
transgender as transgender and a woman
of color Delaware County Councilman Ryan
Webb announced that he now identifies as
an indian-american woman
since that announcement he's received
some support but a lot of backlash many
calling him childish despicable even
calling for things like execution
yeah that's always how the woke left
responds isn't it you must execute him
um now he issued a statement after the
fury Ryan Webbie said after much
consideration I've decided to come out
and finally feel comfortable announcing
my true authentic self this is Ryan Webb
uh he said it is with great relief that
I announced to everyone that I identify
as a woman not just any woman but as a
woman of color as well I guess this
would make me gay lesbian as well since
I'm attracted to women phoo that felt
good to finally get back out there and
start living my life it's my true self
well miss Webb's statement has not been
met with the empathy and gushing support
normally extended by the work Community
some have even demanded that he was Zion
they resign well that he has basically
made a hate speech in this post on April
11th
and I feel that he should resign and if
he doesn't I would I would look at
County Council to talk to legal and see
what they can do about removing him
because he has created some hate and
Discord and divide what the transgender
population here in Muncie
he must be executed he must be canceled
he must be fired it's the usual
predictable response to what was
obviously a joke but it was a smart joke
because actually what he did was expose
the farce of Limitless self-identity
like myself identified on International
women's day as a black lesbian why
shouldn't I be able to if you can
identify anything you want Esther's
cackle when I said that way around the
world well Ryan Webb joins me now uh
alongside talking to these Nicholas
thought Mr Crackers I've just said well
Ryan thank you for joining me so I did
chuckle because I had a similar thing
myself which you may or may not have
heard about when I did a similar stunt
uh but you were making the same point I
think which is if we really want to have
a world where anyone can identify as
anything well why shouldn't you be able
to identify as a woman of color
well Pierce uh you're absolutely right
and I I appreciate it I want to thank
you for bringing me on the show and uh
as a fellow lesbian woman of color
um I feel we have a deep connection here
but you're right they've uh they've laid
the groundwork they set it up where
anybody can be anything that they want
uh just by simply declaring it and um
you know that's what we're doing here
and uh turns out that they don't really
feel as strongly about that and believe
it in their soul as they would make you
believe because um I wasn't really as
accepted in the beginning as you would
think someone of my stature would be
yeah and the reaction was unbelievably
vicious people calling for you to be
executed of course they wanted you fired
of course they wanted you canceled in
all entirely predictable because it's
fine for them
on the other side of this debate to
identify as whatever they want
but the moment you dared to identify as
what you decided you wanted to be for
that day all hell bracelets it's the
double standard
well uh predictably uh the political
left they they always implode on their
own ideology
um I've made a statement that I'm just
holding up the mirror uh to them and
they're doing all the damage themselves
I've just stepped back and uh with their
own words and their own actions they're
just uh dismantling their entire
ideology that they've worked very hard
to build up to this point
um and in my opinion they've turned the
clock back uh two three years
um you know just a few days ago all you
had to do uh if you wanted to
self-identify as anyone as you choose is
just declare it and it was a universal
truth that that had to be accepted but
now uh the truth is clear that uh that's
not the case now I'm being told you have
to do hormone treatments you have to
start dressing the park you have to wear
the makeup you have to change your
identification
um so you know they've turned the clock
back on their own movement a few years
it's disappointing to see them give up
so quickly on uh something that they
said they believe in so strongly you
know what Ron I had to chuckle watching
genuine news reports having to report
this legitimately because how else could
they do it without obviously
disrespecting you without respecting
your right to self-identity which it
just made me laugh Ryan I appreciate you
joining me uh Piers Morgan has censored
thank you what are you currently
identifying as
I'm currently uh at the same time I'm
still identifying as a woman of color
and I've I've said uh in a few other
times these Journeys are often complex
and uh you know sometimes we never know
where they're going to take us we could
end up right back where we started I'm
just riding uh I'm just riding the wave
and wherever it takes me that's where
I'll be well I wish you all the very
best with your journey Ryan and thank
you very much indeed for joining me
thank you
all right it's a it's a good laugh I'm
watching the news reports was hilarious
but Nick like I see you've fulminating
as you were listening to this but why
because just as I was doing all he's
really saying is look if we genuinely
are moving to Limitless self-identity
why not this is where it can go well we
are though we're not moving to limit we
are self-identity there's male female
non-binary that's it that's not it BBC
teachers are a hundreds of General
genders is different genders is
different we're talking what sex is
non-binary those but somewhere between
male and female identity of 100 gender
identities non-binary is nothing there
are not binaries the BBC and various
other outlets have said I hear the 72
genders quite often that's just 72
different ways of describing something
you could also argue there's only three
colors red yellow and blue but a mixture
of all those make multitudes of colors
it's the same thing with uh how did you
feel for example how did you feel about
an American cyclist Austin killitz
becoming the first transgender athlete
to women up to win a women's
professional stage race yes right this
has caused complete outrage and
apparently the vast majority you see
towering over the female uh competitors
but here's to say that height
necessarily gives you an advantage
clearly but but a lot of people because
like all these trans athletes when you
look at how they competed as males they
didn't compete with anything like the
success so clearly they have a physical
biological Advantage purely from having
gone through puberty it is indisputable
so anyone who tries the moment I hear
anyone on this side of the trans
activist argument I support trans rights
to fairness inequality but the moment I
hear anyone on that side of the argument
trying to defend what's happening in
sport in women's sport they lose me
because you're denying biological facts
but you know how many trans athletes
that have more and more competing in the
Olympics more but one okay so here's
what you do with the Olympics let's
remove any specific gender from Olympic
qualification okay what do you think
would happen well that's what happened
what would happen yeah is that how many
women would compete in the Olympics if
it was gender neutral probably just as
many women would compete but on certain
Sports
they wouldn't qualify no women would
qualify okay apart from equestrian and
shooting I think everything else
there is a reason we separate the sex
stories yes because men generally speak
English
wouldn't win any medals because it's
unfair women so why is it fair for
people who are biological males to put
their hand up and send a woman and
compete against biological feelings
because you're being it's cheating they
don't have to put just put their hands
up and say I'm a woman they have to
transition for two years and for two
years they have to be on hormone
replacement therapy can I ask the
question because I feel how is this in
line with the doping anti-doping
legislation because you on one hand you
have people like Serena Williams who
actually failed a drug test for taking
too much aspirin but you're allowing
biological
bodies full of all sorts of hormones so
their testosterone levels it's not all
women are by the way we're much more
than just a social exactly I agree
well Austin Killers won't be having
periods every month which will affect
training for example I don't have
periods every month well that you're
unique I'm sorry no a lot of women don't
appears any month if you're on your coil
well right
a lot of sports women have told me that
is rarely mentioned is one of the
reasons why it's also incredibly unfair
but you just have to see Austin Phillips
towering over the biological
Brian Webb is not being genuine and
that's why the people on the left such
as what is the standard of genuine no
he's he's genuinely sending up the
hypocrisy he's sending up that hypocrisy
as you were saying you know I want to
identify as a black lesbian okay so
nobody is saying that you can identify
as a different race or you can identify
even though it's more logical why can't
race actually is a spectrum exactly
sexism I actually had my DNA done and I
discovered I had no English DNA
whatsoever mainly celt so it was like
Scottish a lot of Irish but hang on at
six percent Middle Eastern so am I an
Arab yeah six percent of you
I can identify as Arabic yeah but
ultimately you are and you would say a
most Arabic people would say what are
you talking about you're not you're born
in England you're a white guy you're not
Arabic right however it's more
complicated far more complicated than
biological sex yeah biological sex like
can you define for me then what is a
biological or whatever man yeah it's a
it's an adult male and what is it that's
a male and an adult male is an adult
male it's a biology
fact-based thing but what's it what
makes Departments of Australia
chromosomes Australia what is a woman
and he replied it's an adult female this
is not difficult but what defines a man
the chromosomes and they sell in a
male's body let's play the Prime
Minister of Australia very easily but
what is a woman prime minister an adult
female how difficult was that to answer
not too hard he was just on Time
magazine's 100 most influential lists
named by Justin Trudeau the wokest human
being in the history of planet Earth as
the champion of progressive politics
around the world even he understands
what a woman is you know what's happened
to him today all around Australia
absolutely buried with abuse from the
trans activist mob who say what he said
there was transphobic transphobic for
saying a woman is an adult female
let's take a break when we come back we
will discuss the world's most privileged
pampered pre-madonas not these two who
turned out in their droves to honor the
late Carl Lagerfeld the assembly
designer who was of course the
antithesis of everything that they stand
for this is Hollywood hypocrisy at its
best
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
for the real crown experience tune in to
talk TV all this week for a rightful
point of view don't miss Piers Morgan
very smartly he's now moving to save the
monarchy Jeremy Kyle it really is a
Monumental moment whether you're a
monarchist or not Vanessa Felts we can't
wait we're counting down we've got the
mud we've got the Bunting and TV Queen
Mrs o he is a humanitarian and he's
going to do a great job only on top TV
[Music]
thank you
he's back and he's uncensored debating
the breaking news and talking to the
biggest names Piers Morgan is live every
week with a host of stars uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember
if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
thank you
for the real crown experience tune in to
talk TV all this week for a right Royal
point of view don't miss Piers Morgan
very smartly he's now moving to save the
monarchy Jeremy Kyle it really is a
Monumental moment whether you're a
monarchist or not Vanessa Felts we can't
wait we're counting down we've got the
mug we've got the Bunting and TV Queen
Mrs o he is a humanitarian and he's
going to do a great job only on top TV
[Music]
thank you
hello Darlings I'm back at nine o'clock
tonight yes welcome back to share and
also on the talk we're looking at the
coronation security Crackdown after a
man was arrested at Buckingham Palace a
third of Brits want to get rid of God
Save the King and replace it with a
different national anthem and we have
been taking the talk on tour find out
where we've been at nine
[Music]
okay well we're going to talk about this
daggering hypocrisy of the Met Gala
stars all pouring in to pay tribute to
Carl Lagerfeld who was the least woke
human being ever great designer but he
had outrageous views about almost
everything that that lot would have
normally hated so Nicola incredibly you
read a column I wrote about this for New
York Post and you found yourself
agreeing with me even a broken clock is
right twice and I found myself agreeing
with Jamila Jamil which the words I
never thought I'd use because she's as
she rightly pointed out if you are on
the left if you're awoke left and this
is the double standard you deploy yeah
you lose all credibility when you try
and deploy it against the other side it
was enraging
um I was flicking through my Instagram
over the weekend and seeing photos of
people who I admire people I looked up
to people who had been outspoken on
issues of fat phobia issues within um
the metoo movement homophobia precisely
you know he he mocked me two victims he
he mocked models who complain about
being groped he was openly homophobic he
was you know he he abused Muslim
refugees in a vile manner called them
the enemy of the of the Jewish people in
Germany and invoke the Holocaust and yet
there they all are he's my hero he's a
if that had been Donald Trump saying
that stuff they'd be marching to the
streets so many of them dressing as him
as well and it goes to show when money's
involved or a career advancement is
involved for a nice dress and a party
well for them to drop their morals and
it annoys people such as myself people
who genuinely do believe in these causes
because we will get a bad name we'll get
called the woke left well you see
yourself as a principal Council galter
cultural okay principle Council culture
yeah sounds good
but I think for people that make this
their resonator I think how far does it
go like who would actually be because no
one is blameless right you can always
dig up something from someone's past and
find something you disagree with so I I
just I'm curious where the standard is
yes Carl Lagerfeld was a horrible person
but I just think there's no no don't get
me don't get me wrong I think I look I
think a lot of people are flawed right
and they should be taken in totality he
was obviously a brilliant designer
allegedly designer however it really the
column I wrote wasn't about an attack on
Carl Lagerfeld even though some of his
views were clearly pretty reprehensible
I don't agree with him he's entitled to
his views yeah my attack was on the
hypocrisy of course of all these very
woke Hollywood stars who are openly all
the time preaching about all these
things and yet are happy to call him a
hero but they're not truly whoa can I
use the word well I agree they're
shallow this is the thing it's because
it's now become a church I don't have a
problem with these people you know
saying the things that they do and I
suppose sporting carlographer and the
way that they do but that's because that
just means that the public shouldn't
take what they have to say by the way I
don't think anything I don't think I
don't think anyone is truly woke
Define the word woke now has changed and
it's been defined by people like
yourself it well originally is being
aware and having an awareness I agree
social interest what it now means is you
don't mind if a six foot four inch bloke
gets on a swimming pool and demolishes
women's swimming records that's all
being woke means you know what you can
stick it lovely to see you Nicholas
lovely to see you yesterday that's it
from me I'm going to leave you again
with a fantastic Catherine Jenkins
singing Jerusalem if this doesn't get
your heart pounding with British Pride
what will keep it uncensored good night
[Music]
and did those fears
walk upon England's
mountains green
and was
[Music]
Divine Shine for them
is
[Music]
toys
foreign
[Music]
to either
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
for the real crown experience tune in to
talk TV all this week for a rightful
point of view don't miss Piers Morgan
very smartly he's now moving to save the
monarchy Jeremy Kyle it really is a
Monumental moment whether you're a
monarchist or not Vanessa Felts we can't
wait we're counting down we've got the
mud we've got the Bunting and TV Queen
Mrs o he is a humanitarian and he's
going to do a great job only on top TV
thank you
[Music]
foreign
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember
if you're thinking it